you know usually when I say hey here's
what the right is saying and here's why
it doesn't make sense because a could
happen and B could happen
A and B don't usually happen within like
a few days but with the entire
definition of a woman thing it has now
happened with Republican senator Josh
Hawley and we're going to look at it
because it's exactly why I said the idea
that it's so simple to Define woman as
far as Republicans are concerned really
isn't borne out by the actual fact so
let's backtrack a little bit
when Judge katanji Brown Jackson's
confirmation hearings were going on
Senator Marsha blackburner Republican
said can you define a woman and judge
Jackson said you know in the context of
legality I really can't because when we
figure out if the question is who can
bring a gender discrimination lawsuit it
depends on the specific facts of a case
so I can't really tell you and then she
went on to say I'm also not a biologist
so I can't give you like a biological
definition I'm I'm a judge and one of
the things I said to you guys was it's
not as simple as it seems and within a
few days I appeared on the right wing
Michael Knowles show and he suggested
the definition for a woman anyone who's
not a man and of course that doesn't
really work it ignores intersex people
and then he said well it's a human that
produces eggs well there's lots of
conditions like hormonal imbalances and
thyroid conditions and things in the
womb and pituitary tumors which prevent
women from producing eggs but they're
still women
uh and then there was well capable of
reproduction through pregnancy lots of
conditions inhibit reproduction what
about post-menopausal woman uh what
about apost menopausal woman what about
a woman who has had a hysterectomy well
the by his by that definition they
wouldn't be a woman
this brings us to Republican senator
Josh Hawley who was recently asked about
this and in fact HuffPost asked a bunch
of Republican Senators can you define
woman and most of them didn't even
answer probably because they realized
even though we pretended it was really
easy for judge Jackson to answer we're
not answering either but Josh Josh Holly
did to his credit and Josh Hawley
initially said someone who can give
birth to a child a mother is a woman
someone who has a uterus is a woman it
doesn't seem that complicated to me
and so the follow-up was what if a woman
has her uterus removed by a hysterectomy
is she still a woman and Josh Hawley
initially said yeah well I don't know
would they
and the answer was yes and later when
Josh Hawley was asked well would you
consider a woman to be a woman if she
lost her reproductive organs to cancer
Holly said I mean a woman still has a
vagina right which is a different
definition first it was capable of
reproduction then it was like well
actually that's not the definition it's
having a vagina and then of course there
are trans women who have vaginas he
wasn't asked about that but the point
here is these definitions don't work in
figuring out
who is a woman
for specific purposes right if the
question is who is a woman
for needing OB GYN care well there are
definitely some trans women that don't
need an OB GYN but then there's a
different question who is a woman for
the purposes of bringing a gender
discrimination lawsuit and that's a
different definition so the most
important takeaway is they want
everybody else to think there's one
definition for all contexts and it's
really simple and anyone who doesn't
give you that definition is being
dishonest or they're being unrealistic
or whatever
and even Josh hawley's definition uh
that came from him already ran into a
bunch of problems needing him to
backpedal so if we need any reminder
that it's not as simple as they make it
out to be we now have as a data point
that Josh Hawley himself who was on
those confirmation hearings for judge
Jackson although he didn't ask these
particular questions he's already had to
revise his definition very interesting
data point
um when the people who follow you
politically
are number one willing and able to be
convinced of anything you tell them even
if it's not true and number two willing
to do violence
you have to be really careful when
you're telling them lies and this is
more true than ever with the modern
reactionary right we might call it the
neo-reactionary right I don't know what
to call them because again as I've said
before
these trumpists aren't conservative by
the traditional definitions they weren't
even really involved in politics many of
them until Trump came up there really
are neo-reactionary movement and the
problem is that the people feeding them
drivel and pablum have no consideration
for whether these folks are going to
hear what they say and go and take real
world violent action and it's already
happened it's already happened which
we're going to talk about in a moment
but this brings us to something that
radical republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green recently said
she and some others have gotten on this
idea that anybody who supports uh Judge
katanji Brown Jackson for the Supreme
Court is either a pedophile or is pro
pedophilia now you might say wait but
David what that doesn't make any sense
you'd be right it doesn't make any sense
but but the way they have spun this is
judge Jackson has issued sentences for
all sorts of different crimes to all
sorts of different people over many
years as a judge in different uh on
different courts and sometimes the
sentence she gives is not what the state
asks for what the prosecution asks for
sometimes it's somewhere between what
the prosecution asks for and what the
defense asks for and as all judges do
she weighs factors and issues a sentence
and the fact that that happened with
some examples of individuals who had
explicit images of children what is
sometimes called child porn although I
don't think that's a good term because
porn typically is legal and between
involving consenting individuals child
porn is something very different I've
already said that sometimes her sentence
has departed from the recommendation or
what the prosecutors wanted so they're
saying she's Pro pedophile and the
people supporting her might be
pedophiles themselves here is such an
example of Marjorie Taylor green saying
that the Democrats are are the party of
pedophiles the Democrats are the party
of Princess Predators from Disney the
Democrats are the party of of teachers
Elementary School teachers trying to
trying to transition their Elementary
school-aged children and convince them
they're a different gender this is the
party of their identity and their
identity is the most disgusting evil
horrible things happening in our country
and that's why we have to say it we have
to be willing to say it and no matter
how many little blue check marks get
their feelings hurt on Twitter so you
know it's worth talking
this is liable to get people killed now
why is that well we have a dangerous
cult here we have a dangerous cult that
refuses to or is unable to think
critically about the things that they're
being told we have a cult that by a lot
much larger uh share than Independence
and Democrats believes it's okay to use
real world violence to achieve political
goals
so they believe things that aren't true
and they're willing to use violence and
this could genuinely lead
some of Marjorie Taylor Green's
followers and other trumpists to go and
Target Democrats with guns or even the
three Republicans who said they'd be
voting for uh Judge catanji Brown
Jackson remember we looked at this on
the show a couple days ago Marjorie
Taylor green tweeted murkowski Collins
and Romney are pro pedophile they just
voted for kbj
uh this is extraordinarily dangerous and
we have examples of it remember there
was this one story of the man who was uh
targeting liberals and the tides
Foundation this is an old story this is
11 years old I remember covering this
when it happened Byron Williams told
investigators he wanted to start a
revolution by killing people of
importance at the tides foundation and
the ACLU
where did he get that idea
well he got it among others from Glenn
Beck and he said that when California
Highway Patrol pulled him over we we did
the story we have the pizza gate shooter
pizzagate gunman this is from 2017
sentenced to four years in prison this
was a guy who became convinced thanks to
what Republicans were saying at the time
that Comet Ping Pong a pizza shop in DC
was somehow the Nexus of some kind of
child sex trafficking ring involving
Democrats and I mean listen I don't
remember exactly all the claims they
were making but it was completely and
totally Bonkers there was the pipe
bomber the trumpist pipe bomber I don't
even remember the date it was while
Donald Trump was president who was also
caught this is not like maybe it'll
happen someday we know that these types
of comments from people like Marjorie
Taylor green are stochastic terrorism
it's extraordinarily dangerous and she's
going to get people killed let me know
your thoughts find me on Twitter at
dpacman and remember that Tuesday April
19th we'll be doing the next David
Pacman show Town Hall it'll be at 6 PM
eastern time on the Pac-Man Live YouTube
channel that's youtube.com
pacmanlive we'll take a quick break and
be right back so there continues to be
something very wrong with many of the
reporters regularly in the White House
Press briefing room just determined to
ask ridiculous questions of gen Saki and
in this segment we're going to look at
two clips one is Steve Portnoy from CBS
News Now what Steve Portnoy does is less
about Steve and it's more about
something many reporters have been doing
in corporate media since the Russian
invasion of Ukraine started then we'll
look at Peter Ducey who is kind of a
different type of of character in these
situations asking different types of
questions but they're all absurd so
first question Steve Portnoy from CBS
News ask Jen Saki
why is the United States
not pushing for like a real world war
against Russia at this point in time and
there seems to be and I think we know
why a real desire among many in
corporate media
to see that happen to see what's
happening with Russia and Ukraine boil
over into a true World War and Jen saki
does some good things here including
asking specifically what exactly is it
you would like to see take a look why
shouldn't the images of the atrocities
compel a worldwide unified
Coalition kinetic response you mean a
military war tell me more about what you
mean or a military response led by the
United States and the international
Partners as in bringing military troops
on the ground from the United States and
NATO well the president's described
outrageous things you call them
atrocities you've said perhaps we should
brace ourselves for Worse
why not I think what the president's
objective is and his responsibility is
to make decisions that are in the
interests of the United States and the
National Security of the United States
and the American people and that is not
to go to war with Russia it is to do
everything in our power to hold them
accountable to support efforts through
International systems to do exactly that
and to provide military assistance
security assistance and support to the
Ukrainian people and the Ukrainian
government that's exactly what we're
doing but it is not in our interests or
in the interests of the American people
for us to be in a war with Russia go
ahead
so
I
I don't I don't even know if Steve
Portnoy personally has this view but
much of the corporate media has decided
probably correctly if you look at
history that if there was really like a
full-scale war against Russia uh or
against Russia in Ukraine maybe better
said that it would be great for
corporate media ratings and and it's
probably true it's probably true I mean
if it bleeds it leads conflict is good
in general for corporate media uh and so
it's not just Steve pornoy that's the
clip that we're looking at here but many
in right wing media have been asking
both Joe Biden and gen saki questions
like they're in corporate media have
been asking gen Saki and uh uh Joe Biden
were you too quick to rule out some
major escalation boots on the ground
sending troops in but drones whatever
um do you think that you're giving Putin
you're emboldening Putin by actually
saying what you're not willing to do or
whatever the case that may be do you
regret not taking a harder position and
they seem to just want the biggest
possible War they seem almost
incredulous that Joe Biden doesn't want
to do that and I commend Joe Biden for
that
um we can have a debate and it can be a
hearty debate and it can be a good faith
debate about what would have been the
right things to do and when when it
comes to Russia and Ukraine going back
we can talk about Crimea in 2014. that's
that's fair that's fair game we can talk
about continued occupation of the
Donetsk and luhansk regions of Ukraine
by Russia while Trump was President
these are all legitimate things but
generally speaking Joe Biden has handled
the situation pretty well he's provided
a ton of support military aid training
to Ukrainian soldiers in Poland
drones has even sent over so if you want
Joe Biden to help hope he's done it and
if you don't want Joe Biden to get us
quote into another War as has become a
popular talking point on the left and
right and generally speaking a talking
point I agree with I don't want war he
has set a line which is we're not
getting boots on the ground
uh but the corporate media seems to be
desperate not because they care
geopolitically I don't think Steve
portno and all these people have
geopolitical motivations it's just about
what's good for corporate media so
that's number one I hope Biden stands
completely firm on no boots on the
ground
separately
we have Peter Ducey and Peter Ducey asks
jensaki would Joe Biden support
appointing a special counsel to
investigate his own son Hunter Biden
yeah let's look at that clip and then
we'll talk about that on another topic a
lot of stories about Hunter Biden
surfacing this week so to ensure the
independence of the investigation would
the president support the appointment of
a special counsel well first the
president has never had a conversation
with the Department of Justice about any
investigations into any member of his
family he said that during the campaign
and he will continue to abide by that so
I appointed the Department of Justice
for any additional steps they would take
they would make those decisions
independently is there any concern that
they're not going to be that necessarily
seen as being able to make the decisions
independently if the white house chief
and staff is out saying that the
president is confident his son did not
break the law well that's something the
president has said and certainly we
would Echo but in the same answer to
that question Peter during an interview
this week comes in ABC Ron Clane also
said the justice department is
independent and they will make their own
decisions and the president has said
that he never spoke to his son about his
overseas feelings is that still the case
yes
so again I had a conversation here in
Las Vegas earlier with Farren cousins
from ring of fire and we talked a little
about a little bit about Hunter Biden
I believe that Joe Biden is doing the
exact right thing when it comes to
Hunter Biden and he's doing what he
promised to do
he is not getting involved and trying to
stop the investigation into Hunter
Biden's business dealings in 2018.
presidents shouldn't on the one hand
presidents shouldn't try to get the
justice department to investigate
anybody in particular and Joe Biden
isn't doing that and he could there's
plenty of people from the Trump era that
Joe Biden could be going to the justice
department and saying hey this is
something you should really be looking
at investigate this charge people maybe
he's not doing that that's correct and
he's also not trying to obstruct the
investigation into Hunter Biden that is
exactly what Joe Biden should have no
involvement and as I've said before I
couldn't care less about Hunter Biden if
Hunter Biden committed crimes charge him
if Hunter Biden is found guilty of
crimes punish him it just has nothing to
do with Joe Biden's Administration and
there's also a confusion happening
between the investigation into Hunter
Biden and the laptop
the investigation doesn't have anything
to do with a laptop and a lot of people
also don't seem to understand that uh
reporters just really making fools of
themselves every single day in that
press briefing room
guys I love the story
Mike pillow Mike Lindell the CEO of
MyPillow
he was just finishing up giving a speech
in Colorado and he was served with a
lawsuit on camera this is I love this
the I relish this is it schadenfreude
shot and fraud ah every time I say it
someone emails me and says David you're
pronouncing it wrong you guys know
exactly what I'm talking about as Mike
pillow is walking away from a speech
about election Integrity in Colorado he
gets served by Eric coomer's defamation
lawsuit Eric Coomer is this former
employee of dominion voting systems
pillow has been hammering on Kumar for a
while and uh the best part about this
video is initially pillow doesn't
realize he's being served legally here
and he tries to kind of walk away and
says he doesn't want the papers then he
realizes he's been served and he looks
dejected and he sounds dejected and I
love it I really do take a look at this
video listen to the audio
everybody
thank you Mike thank you for everything
what is this sure sure what is this it's
for you okay well what is not for me
hey I need you to open it is sorry
it's always nice to have video evidence
of proof of service Sue all these guys
if the facts point that way Sue every
single one of them and it's I don't know
if this is even a guilty pleasure of
mine
but you really love to see it and I
don't know that Mike pillow realizes the
amount of trouble that he's in this
really could destroy him financially he
has a lot of money I know it really
could Sydney Powell the other uh she was
I guess she still is a lawyer even
though she's been disbarred a bunch of
places she was pushing a lot of these
bogus frivolous legal complaints around
the 2020 election I'm not you never hear
me say sue them
I I say sue them if the evidence points
to it and it seems that the evidence
points to lawsuits against Mike pillow
and one of the things that again we talk
about projection the right generally
speaking it's the right that says we
need tort reform
we which Often by the tort reform they
mean we need to make it more difficult
for individuals to be able to hold
corporations accountable you have to
understand in general when they when the
right talks about tort reform they mean
let's make it easier for corporations to
do whatever the hell they want
and make it more difficult for them to
be held accountable they talk all the
time about frivolous lawsuits frivolous
oh this lawsuit's frivolous that lawsuit
is frivolous uh courts can determine
that courts have courts are very well
equipped to determine whether a lawsuit
should or shouldn't move forward and if
it shouldn't they dismiss lawsuits and
one of the things that was found by
courts is that they were filing the
frivolous lawsuits and frivolous legal
complaints in the aftermath of the 2020
election and if they've done it in a way
that is systematic and is a waste of the
Court's time 100 hold them accountable
pillows getting sued again and he's got
a big legal bill coming and something
about that video that video is from
Marshall zellinger with nine news really
good job of of zellinger was just there
and he happened to get the process uh
server delivering the papers it's just
fantastic
he has got a big uphill legal battle in
front of him and of course he continues
to claim pillow does that we're like
days from the evidence coming out or
whatever it's wacky these people are
Bonkers and unfortunately a lot of their
followers believe every word they say so
we'll track this lawsuit but you really
love to see that clip if you didn't if
you're listening today and you're not
watching you can see the delivery of the
papers we'll have it on our Instagram at
davidpackman show it's great to Welcome
to the program today Bill Von hippel
who's a professor of psychology at the
University of Queensland in Australia
and also author of the book The Social
leap the new evolutionary science of who
we are where we came from and what makes
us happy uh so great to have you on
today I really appreciate it uh thanks
for having me David so I mean I guess to
pick somewhere to start there's often
conversations about when when were
humans modern and when would we look at
past humans and say yeah at least
physically and generally speaking that's
the same sort of species that that is us
um but there's maybe a little bit less
time paid in popular culture to what was
Humanity like at sort of some of those
earlier stages so maybe we go to the
kind of rain forest to Savannah phase
talk to us a little bit about what would
be the big differences we'd notice I
guess
sure so if you go back to when we were
still the same species as our cousins
the chimpanzees so we're talking six or
seven million years ago living in the
rain forest all the data that we have
suggests that we would look a lot like
modern chimps not exactly but awfully
close and then when we left the
rainforest and moved to the Savannah and
actually it was the rainforest that left
us it dried out in the region that we
were on but when we left it moved to the
Savannah we were still probably very
chimp-like for a long time and in fact
if you fast forward the clock about
three million years to
australopithecines you could see them
standing next to a chimp and the primary
difference between them would be that
the australopithecines can stand
straight up that they're completely
bipedal but they they look awfully a lot
like a chimp they
um in their structure and almost
everything else about them it doesn't
look like we're moving anything towards
Humanity it's not really until about 1.7
million years ago maybe two million
years ago when we get to Homo erectus
that we start to see an ancestor who you
would expect to be on your side of the
glass at the zoo rather than on the
other side when we talk about modern
humans it is the best science we have
still that that phase goes back about
250
000 years
yeah that's a that's a great number the
downside of course is that there wasn't
one day where we were or weren't humans
and then were right and so it's very
slow spread when you look at fossils
that are a little older than that you
start to see features that don't look a
lot like modern humans but just a few
and when you look at fossils that are
younger than that you even occasionally
see things that look a little archaic as
well there are many efforts made by
sometimes I I don't want to say modern
psychology like pejoratively but but by
some Modern psychologists sometimes to
explain certain uh responses that we
humans have today to certain stimuli by
telling stories about what things would
have been like when humans were on the
Savannah you know the idea of the the
fight or flight response which we might
have now in public speaking you often
hear analogies too well it's better to
err on the side of if there might be a
lion coming to have sort of that
reaction another example is I recently
spoke to an expert on sleep paralysis
and other conditions and we we talked
about the very common dream of of
falling and his idea was that may go
back to when we were in the trees and
there would be an evolutionary advantage
to having that kind of startle response
even when it's only a dream that you
were falling because it might you might
really be sort of falling out of a tree
those stories how useful do you think
they really are and kind of thinking
about our past
I think they're useful sometimes but
they're really primarily useful in
developing hypotheses and so if you
think well public speaking maybe that's
some sort of ancient response to her to
Lions or sabertooths on the Savannah
something like that well you need to
explore that hypothesis and say what
does that tell us now personally I don't
wouldn't think that would get you
anywhere because what was a bigger deal
to our ancestors was was no longer
sabertooths on the Savannah but the
possibility that our group might reject
us and if ever there's a chance to my
group reject me all at once is when I'm
publicly speaking and I'm saying
something to everybody if I say
something wrong that's a great chance
for them all to agree all right time to
give Bill the hippo which for our
ancestors was a death sentence that's
interesting that's interesting so and I
think and you've written quite a bit
about how social behavior
may be heavily dictated today by our
ancient ancestors and The evolutionary
pressure so that would be taking a it's
the same story that's often told but
it's really applying more of a social
interpretation to it than a biological
one I guess absolutely and then the key
is you need to find a way to try to test
it and most of the research that we've
done for example on rejection shows that
our responses are way stronger than they
are to the fear of
um predators and other physical stimuli
a cliff you might fall off something
like that the social rejection thing
Jonathan height has written about this a
little bit and and also including in
terms of uh religiosity where in the
past if you didn't go with the
predominant beliefs of the clan it might
increase the odds that you get rejected
and at the time it was much more it was
less trivial to be socially rejected
maybe than it is now in terms of our
survival where now one could argue I
don't really have to be part of a church
or I can even be alone owner and at
least stay alive to a greater degree can
you talk a little bit about how that
that rejection risk has really changed
over time
well the funny thing about that
rejection risk is as you say it hardly
matters anymore Not only would you and I
be just fine if all of our friends
decided they didn't like us because we
could still survive but even more
importantly we could move to the new
neighborhood and get a new set of
friends but our ancestors didn't live
like that they lived in groups that were
relatively close so to speak they broke
up and and regathered but in only within
a relatively small Clan and so they
couldn't afford to risk their reputation
in the same way that you and I can today
and this is the exact kind of
evolutionary disconnect that you were
talking about earlier in our past it
mattered a great deal now it probably
doesn't matter as much but there's
nothing more painful to people than
rejection and there's nothing that
drives us more than people making fun of
us people doing the kinds of things that
we see our hunt together ancestors do
before they reject a member of the group
they ostracize them they tease them
ostracizing and teasing make us feel
terrible because those ancestors who
wouldn't respond to that are the ones
who then they took the next step and
they gave them the hippo
thinking still along these lines I've
heard folks like for example Jordan
Peterson make the argument that the
possibility of a physical confrontation
between men that's kind of he he would
say always there in in the kind of
background and socially important is a
driving factor in many ways for the
advancement of society in some way and I
say this both as someone who I hope I'm
representing accurately what he said and
I'm also not a Peterson Fanboy I've been
very critical of many things he said I'm
just interested in the idea that there's
this when men interact in society in
Western Society at least there's the
possibility that if things don't go well
it may devolve into a physical
confrontation can you talk a little bit
about whether that's a conflict with
what others say is the human kind of
proclivity for peaceful relations rather
than than a violent relations and see if
we can make make a little bit of sense
out of that yeah that's a great question
so if you look at our chimpanzee cousins
they're about 500 times as likely to
come into physical conflict with other
members of their group than humans are
and so when we look at human
hunter-gatherers so there's no police to
stop you no government we see a ratio of
500 to 1 for every one conflict we have
where we fight with each other over
something they have 500 but if you look
at our chimpanzee cousins when they
interact with members of other groups
now you see a one-to-one ratio they're
exactly as conflicted with members of
other groups as we are or we are exactly
as much as they and so basically we've
we've evolved to be hyper Cooperative we
work together incredibly well but that's
primarily within our groups when we're
looking at between group relationships
they look a lot like chimpanzees did and
so human males in particular are the
ones who when the conflict comes they
tend to get into it but if you look at
us within our groups although we form
shallower relationships than human
females do on average those shallow
relationships allow us to kind of form
coalitions that dissipate and then that
reform later without any hard feelings
but those coalitions almost never get
formed when we cross group boundaries
and that's where we see the real
violence that's part of our nature is
the explanation for this simply that if
you work together rather than fight with
each other everybody's more likely to
survive both as a species and as a
community and as an individual
well yes and and the reason that the
chimpanzees never crossed that
particular Rubicon is they never got to
the point that we got to on the Savannah
where there was enormous benefit to be
gained if everybody would cooperate and
so when you look at chimpanzees
psychology they're very clever they do
lots of things very well but they're
fundamentally competitive with one
another as a consequence the individual
goals and the group goals never aligned
whereas once we moved to the Savannah
once we became bipedal and now we could
protect ourselves from predators now our
individual goals came into alignment
with our group goals and as a
consequence it benefited us individually
to cooperate and it made us incredibly
successful as an evolutionary story
that's very interesting in thinking back
I mean there's some characteristics that
now seems sort of trivial like for
example eyesight you know you're wearing
glasses I wear contact lenses it's not a
big deal you know we adjust the
prescription as needed and we can
imagine a time in the past where that
might have conferred a much more
significant disadvantage to us sort of
as as individuals if we think about the
humans that have been leaders in early
Clans and humans that are leaders now
have the characteristics changed
significantly or have they sort of
remained the same from what we know
well it's um it's a bit of a a
complicated story because if you look at
what we what our ancestors were almost
assuredly like for the longest time
which is immediate return on
hunter-gatherers you eat today what you
kill today because you live pretty much
on the equator and meat rots pretty
quickly and so everybody shares it all
out in those societies there are no
Paramount leaders there are leaders that
come and go as decisions are being made
and so maybe you're the best hunter and
when it's time to go on a hunt we all
turn to you and we say okay David what
do you think where should we go now if
you come up with an idea we don't like
we still don't do it but you carry a
little more weight you have more
Prestige because you're better at it but
now it comes time to look for water or
or find a new camp or try to decide how
to deal with those hostels around on the
other side of the ridge somebody else
might step forward with the best plan
and so the what makes leadership
effective in hunter-gatherers societies
is that it's very distributed and it's
very egalitarian we shifted away from
that when we moved to
um when we became agriculturalists
because now we could store food and
create stable coalitions Etc but
interestingly the modern world is
Shifting back to that and one way to
look at this disaster in Ukraine is that
you've got a Paramount leader who
nobody's told no to for a very long time
and so it's harder for him to create and
assess whether an idea is good than it
would be for somebody who's
democratically elected who who knows
that they're at the will of the people
they could come and go and their ideas
are more important and they have to be
more persuasive so does this uh Jared
Diamond has written a little bit about
you know when the when the Agricultural
Revolution happened you if you want to
think about it very mathematically all
of a sudden there were repeat people who
started to be responsible for producing
way more calories than they needed and
that caloric Surplus sort of opened the
door to specialization which includes
people who raise kids and also people
who think and people who do politics and
think about law and that type of thing
is that caloric Surplus the the
beginning of sort of the modern idea of
leadership and politicians
very much so and so once we became
sedentary and we could create a caloric
Surplus that we could store you have to
be like I could create a caloric Surplus
in the equator by killing a giraffe
right but it's going to be gone that's a
key Point yeah right so being able to
store it is a major thing yeah exactly
so once we get to that point where we
can store it we see Society shifts
dramatically now agriculture enabled
that for most humans but it wasn't
always agriculture they're for example
Hunter gathers in the Pacific Northwest
new with these big salmon runs were
going to come through and so they could
create coalitions that could defend them
from other groups they could catch all
these salmon to enough to last for a
year almost dry them out and now they've
got food for a very long time so
whenever you can create or Source
storable sources of energy you've got
the basis to build the kind of society
that we have whereby you can have
specialization everybody doesn't have to
be a hunter or gather people can do
whatever they want because somebody else
can be responsible for generating that
caloric Surplus it's often very uh
there's a lot of black white writing
about all of these significant leaps
forward like the Agricultural Revolution
the Industrial Revolution and some some
folks at least seem driven to assign
good or bad to them overall which which
seems so fraught and difficult
I'm wondering if there's maybe a more
overarching theme that we could identify
about all of these leaps like for
example a lot of these leaps bring the
opportunity for a lot of good but also
things that are not so good so for
example with agriculture we could say
well uh all of the obvious good things
and specialization and potentially
reducing hunger at the same time you
started seeing you know animal-borne
disease to some degree you started
seeing uh Inequality For the First Time
In terms of hey a lot of people can
actually store the food for the future
is the general thing that there's always
going to be some aspects that are
problematic with any advance
yeah I've never seen in advance that was
an unmitigated good there there's almost
always a cost now sometimes we don't
Envision those costs until later and
sometimes we don't Envision the benefits
till later the first agriculturalists
live shorter lives they have more
disease ridden and they were even they
were physically shorter than their hunt
together ancestors because their diet
wasn't as good so they actually suffered
a lot for us to benefit way later you
know a weird deal would you take a deal
to say well in a thousand Generations
things are going to be great you'd say
well no thanks I'll do something else so
that's one side of the coin I think the
internet is a good example the other
side of the coin it's democratized
knowledge it's made us more we can
connect with each other more easily Etc
but it's also done things like create
enormous amount of work as everybody in
the world sends me an email with a
request for something it's created and
used to be they have to write me a
letter and it was just too much effort
right it's created all sorts of
polarization as people can create fake
news sites and and literally your job is
to try to make it more persuasive so
with all of these when we enhance our
abilities to communicate with each other
when we enhance our abilities to create
and store new things we always there's
almost always something that's going to
go wrong in that context humans tend to
be really good at fixing those things
and it's as a rule we'd almost never
want to go back and say okay well let's
get rid of the internet let's start
hunting Gathering again right those
things don't happen so we do a great job
of doing our best to fix them but
they're undeniably the problems that
accompany those changes yeah one of the
most interesting books that addresses
this specifically with the Internet is
that I've read as Neil postman's book
technopoly where he talks about the sort
of I don't know if it's naivete but the
idea that
only sorting things out so that we only
get the good of any technology or
advancement is such an impossibility
that it's almost not even worth trying
it seems better to just figure out how
to deal with and manage the bad
yeah I think that's a great point and
Adam alter has a wonderful book called
irresistible where he also talks about
just social media and the technology
that goes with that and again all that
stuff is great but then it turns out
it's highly addictive and so it disrupts
people's lives because they start
replacing their in-person interactions
with interactions with screens and so
you've got the the approach of
technopoly you've got the problems that
come when you're just psychologically
too attached to these things and you no
longer live the kind of life we're
actually evolved to live Etc every
single time you've there's pluses and
minuses and you have to find a way to
navigate it one of the points you make
in your book if I understand it
correctly is that
um following or letting our evolutionary
needs lead us leads to more happiness
all else being equal and I think that
that's super interesting I'm also aware
of ways in which it sometimes turned
around and used in what I would consider
to be a negative way like for example
sometimes you will hear that type of
argument used by those against gay
marriage and gay adoption Etc to say
that's not going in the direction that
Evolution leads us because two men by
themselves can't create uh Offspring and
so it's a sign that we should be
anti-gay for example or something like
that which I know is not your your point
can you talk a little bit about what you
do mean by happier by following
evolutionary needs
sure so Evolution pushes us to do the
things that help us survive and
reproduce and so to the degree that we
in the modern world continue to do the
things that helped our ancestors survive
and reproduce they're going to make us
happy and that means forming good and
long-lasting relationships that means
forming romantic sexual relationships
the um on the gay point you raise an
interesting one there's actually good
evidence for my colleague Brendan zeech
that homosexuality also evolved and that
it serves purposes as well and so the
same data applied whether you're gay or
straight that Evolution wants you to do
the kinds of things that were in your
best interest now the disconnects the
problems emerge when you get to things
like
um
just when you get to evolutionary
mismatches between our ancestral
environment and today and so a good
example would be we evolved to be
interested in sexual variety because it
helps you sort of spread your genes into
more than one basket you're not taking
all putting all your bet on one person
but variety was so rare in our ancestral
environment that it wasn't that
disruptive to people's long-term
monogamous relationships whereas variety
exists every day outside my door I can
see a new person if I live in a city and
so it makes it really hard to stay in a
long-term relationship if you're a city
dweller in today's world because the
evolved psychology of our ancestors was
we're responding to the fact that they
probably would know 100 people in their
entire lives there's no way they're
encountering a million and the reason
that this was less relevant you say the
variety was less present was it just
because we were in relatively small
groups that were homogeneous yeah yeah
we lived in groups between 20 and 60
people we only mixed with people who had
our same accents spoke our same language
if we ran into somebody who didn't do
that there's we were there was a risk
that they were an enemy we might be
friendly we might get into a conflict if
we were friendly we might even use that
as a chance for men or women to switch
groups to decrease in breeding Etc but
we spent our whole lives in these small
nomadic groups that didn't run into that
many different people
one of the reactions uh that I often see
from 10 11 12 year olds when they you
know learn about evolution is
it seems as though we've stopped
evolving to some degree and and of
course you know when we think about
modern humans 250 000 years we sort of
seem to look the same and and so on and
so forth can we think through a little
bit more about and this maybe this is
more of a futurism type question what
are the evolutionary pressures now
exerting influence on humans again now
that we've solved a lot of the things
that used to kill us very early
yeah that's a great question so if we
look at our at what are called
evolutionary sweeps which are genes that
don't exist in the past and then
suddenly sweep through the population we
can see that in fact they've been more
frequent in the last 10 000 years than
they were in the prior hundred thousand
years so it may look like we stopped
evolving our bodies haven't changed much
but there have been dramatic changes
inside us ways of learning to drink milk
by producing the lactase enzyme
throughout our whole lives lots of
things like that so evolution is still
happening very much at a rapid Pace but
the forces on us are now different it
used to be survival and now survival is
kind of solved right for most of us
we're very fortunate that that modern
medicine and and and agriculture have
enabled us to to not have to worry about
our survival but sexual reproduction is
a big one our ancestors could never
disrupt the link between sexual activity
and reproduction and so that guaranteed
they'd have lots of kids we can now
disrupt that link very easily and
evolution made us want to have sex
because when we were back in the day and
and that desire was important for our
reproduction we didn't understand how to
create Offspring so we've not we don't
have an evolved desire to have kids we
have an evolved desire to have sex and
then evolved tendency to be nurturent to
those beings who come along because of
our sexual activity now that we can
separate out those two I could easily
imagine a world not so far from now 30
40 Generations where there's just not
that many humans because most of us are
not interested in having children most
of us are interested in doing other
things uh when we uh I mean humans are
quite quite poor at making predictions
about what things are going to look like
in the future given that
um what types of changes would you be
thinking about when we think about 500
years from now in terms of homo sapiens
500 years from now I don't think you'll
see anything different physically
biologically that's too fast you'll see
a lot of cultural changes and I have no
idea what those might be you could
imagine world with free energy and then
nobody works for a living you can
imagine lots of interesting
possibilities but as far as us our
bodies and stuff starting to look
different or Evolution starting to make
us
different even psychologically from an
evolutionary basis you you'll need at
least a minimum of a few thousand where
you're going to start to see things in
there it's probably going to have more
to do with who desires to reproduce and
who doesn't and are there differences in
the traits between people who desire to
reproduce and who don't right now those
differences are primarily a factor of
how you live if you're a city dweller
you have fewer kids and if you're a
rural person if you're well educated you
have fewer kids and if you're not but
those are lifestyle factors that push
you down a certain pathway what we don't
know at all is what's the psychology of
somebody who likes to have lots of kids
and what's the psychology of somebody
who doesn't and might those psychologies
then actually play an important role in
our Evolution going forward right right
fascinating uh the book is the social
leap the new evolutionary science of who
we are where we came from and what makes
us happy where we come from not and what
makes us happy we've been speaking with
the books author Bill Von hipple I can't
tell you how much I appreciate your time
today thank you
totally my pleasure great to chat with
you hey this is super interesting me I
David packman uh I am featured in a 2022
campaign ad this is super interesting
now to be clear I I've not endorsed this
candidate they've just used video of me
talking about stuff it doesn't even have
anything to do with Charles Graham but
it's very interesting Charles Graham is
running in North Carolina uh and is
going at David Rouser David Rouser who
is also running in North Carolina and
has previously said how much he likes
Jesse Helms uh the racist far-right
senator who was against civil rights and
against gay rights and against just
about any kind of Rights uh check out
the very beginning of this campaign ad
it's uh very cool to see myself in it
take a look
everything I know in life came from my
years with Elms I had a great education
Jesse Helms used to be a senator who
opposed the Civil Rights Act opposed the
Voting Rights Act called the Civil
Rights Act dangerous I don't think I
ever learned any more than I did when I
was with Senator Helms
yeah so Charles Graham is currently a
member of the North Carolina House of
Representatives for the 47th district
and he's a member of the I hope I'm
pronouncing this correctly the Lumbee
Tribe and Graham is the only Native
American serving in the North Carolina
General Assembly right now and he is
running for North Carolina's ninth
congressional district this is member of
the House of Representatives running
against incumbent Republican Dan bishop
and
um it is a very interesting race and I
want to talk a little more broadly about
our plans for coverage of the midterms
and how people can get involved I'm
getting more and more live call
questions and emails and tweets and
comments from folks saying I want to get
involved in 2022. what are all the best
races I want to be involved in a ton of
races all 435 members of the House are
up for re-election a third of the
members of the senator up for
re-election there's a bunch of
gubernatorial elections I think it's
really important to set expectations and
recognize you can't be involved in every
race you can't phone bank for every race
you can't go out and knock doors for
every race particularly because you know
people generally live in one place and
you're not going to go all over the
country so I understand the instinct to
say I want to do everything I can to try
to prevent Republicans from taking the
house and or the senate or the
governor's mansions in the state that I
live I want to do all of it and I get
that but I think the risk is we spread
ourselves too thin and so my
recommendation would be for everybody in
our audience to pick one or two races
that are either local to you or that you
find to be particularly important if you
live in Florida or Arizona but you find
Mehmet Oz to be a particularly
weaponized dangerous candidate in
Pennsylvania well get to work there
whether it's helping John fetterman who
we're going to try to get on the show or
or whoever else is pick that if your
local district is a purple district and
there's currently a Republican and maybe
a Democrat could win or maybe there's a
Democrat but they're at risk of losing
the seat to a republican Focus there
there's so many interesting races it's
impossible to keep up with all of them
or or even to
uh uh be aware of all of the different
ways that you could volunteer your time
narrow it down and that would be the
approach now many of you have written to
me saying David you should really
interview this primary candidate or that
primary candidate we can't if if we open
up the door to that we risk every day
every show being interviews with primary
candidates and although some of you
might like it most people expect to get
a rundown daily of what's going on
different stories Etc so we really can't
do that and so we're going to try to
pick and choose some interesting races
my colleague John put out a call
recently on social media saying who
should we talk to many of you want me to
talk to both John fetterman and mehmed
Oz We're going to try to make that
happen many of you have talked about
house races Senate races we're going to
try to pick a sort of representative
sample of things and bring it to you
both progressives some incumbent centers
Democrats Republicans we had wacky
Republican candidate Darlene swaffer on
earlier this week so we're going to try
to do a little bit of evidence
everything uh to the extent that we can
but we can't cover every race you can't
possibly pay attention to every race one
last thing
I know that historically
democrats should get crushed in November
there's no question about it we spoke to
Rachel bidikoffer about it and we've
talked about it six ways to Sunday
um but at the same time things are
really weird everything's been weird
since Trump was president and if you
consider that more Republicans than
Democrats have died of covid and that a
lot of the Trump people that got
involved in politics for the first time
to vote for Trump they may not vote in
the fall
and I know it's so cliche because we
always say this but midterms really come
down to turnout and if some Republicans
don't turn out because they're dead and
some Republicans don't turn out because
Trump's not running for anything
um it doesn't have to be a disaster for
Democrats I'm not making a prediction
but it doesn't have to be and there's
really a big opportunity to do some hard
work uh and and maybe retain control of
one or both uh house and or Senate so
that's my thought right now we have more
interviews upcoming for you we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
David P uh the Eggman called in and he
is completely shot out of a cannon
listen to this Dave you slayed that
crazy Republican psycho lady from
Florida but listen when you were talking
about this death tax right and the
federal debt tax doesn't tax you unless
you're over 11.1 million but States
locally can do whatever they want if you
told you that all of her clients that
say leave 250 000 have to pay a bunch of
money to the state you should just ask
her well then do you have a problem with
DeSantis ripping off all the old people
in Florida Governor Rick DeSantis is
still Ron Ron it's not Rick it's Ron but
I understand pulling money from old
people in Florida and she's taking three
thousand dollars from each and every old
person to help them hide and steal their
money from the Santa fact that's some
crooked [ __ ] whoa okay yeah so uh
um yes the the Eggman is correct which
is uh a lot of these folks
so Florida actually doesn't have a state
estate tax that doesn't mean you don't
pay income tax depending on what's going
on but that Florida doesn't have a such
such a an estate tax a state of state
tax
um one of the things that should be
mentioned is the federal government
gives you an 11.7 million dollar
exemption on estate taxes but there are
many States including red states that
don't that they do charge an estate tax
and so there's a real question there
about listen Biden's not taxing the
estate if you've got 5 million you don't
get hit with a federal estate tax but in
many States including red States you do
get hit with a state estate tax why
haven't these Republican Governors fix
that why haven't they dealt with that
because I thought it was the Republican
Governors that wanted to take away taxes
lower your tax burden it's not actually
going on you can Google State estate tax
exemptions and you'll find a lot of
information about it we have a great
bonus show for for you today on today's
bonus show
uh Pat is out I will be taking the
Reigns of the bonus show and we are
going to talk about
what on Earth am I doing in Las Vegas
who have I been seeing here what
happened on my flight what's going on
with covid am I getting coveted on the
trip what's happening in Vegas I'm going
to tell you about my wacky delusional
outrageous lift driver who was a coveted
denying anti-mask
whack job I mean it's I don't even know
what else to call the guy I'm going to
tell you all about it on today's bonus
show sign up at joinpakman.com you'll
get instant access to the bonus show you
can use the coupon code wow22 to get a
discount for yourself if you're already
a member and you want to do something
nice for someone else what's that thing
from each according to their ability I
forget the thing but anyway
630 viewers have asked for a free
membership if you want to request a free
membership you can fill out the form at
davidpackman.com free membership 630
people are waiting for free memberships
you can start helping us chip away at
that by checking the box that says this
is a gift when you sign up at
joinpakman.com and then we'll give away
that gift to somebody on that list of
630 people waiting so do it we will see
you on the bonus show and I will be back
with you tomorrow as well as on the
bonus show normally Pat does the Friday
bonus show this week he did Monday
Tuesday I'm handling Thursday Friday
I'll see you then or tomorrow
foreign